okay let's talk about that stay trashy
tour baby sweet coming in full effect
yeah first leg of the tour has been
announced we went all over the country
gang it's a good good time come out and
see us yeah gang starting in March we're
going to be in Baltimore Virginia Beach
Richmond Oklahoma City Dallas Houston
Austin then in April baby we're hitting
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
then in may we got Tampa Dania Beach
Florida Raleigh North Carolina then in
June we're doing Cleveland and Columbus
get those tickies let's party gang see
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down to your favorite comedians
and we find that they're good to be
classy yeah or they're just a mega old
piece of trash show Birds I'm your
hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she is on a bus
somewhere okay coming back from Disney
World whoa at no fly list is uh jammed
her up can't say bomb in an airplane
can't use your vibrator in there either
apparently she's all hemmed up my
co-host is coming out she was a
lightsaber hahaha
talk about the dark side huh that's
enough of that my co-host is coming at
you from across the table he is the CEO
of Ru garbage an international
businessman if you will he was doing
some deals over there at Norway and
France
and the cop didn't see what was it
didn't know what hit him negotiating a
couple of extra shots in the flugel
floors anyway give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan what up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate review subscribe on iTunes
full video of album YouTube as you know
those numbers are up cooking it and then
obviously the greatest gosh darn website
of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you sign
up over there you get a weekly episode
bonus episodes ayg you get you can get
weekly episodes of hard feelings right
to Disney vid got the Disney vids or
drop we just got back yesterday last
night Disney vids are dropping we got a
whole slew of bonus I think a bajillion
hours we just reached over a jillion
hours of content don't fact check that
but there's a lot of episodes a lot lot
of good vids on there check it out gang
become a homie it's a good time man
homies are having fun over there we're
having fun with them it's a good good
time we love it yep and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones and twos
crosses them T's and dots them eyes give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes what up
t-ban hey pal I think I'm in my final
form in Florida when I go full Florida
buddy Florida is a good time my kind of
peeps I'm talking short flip-flops in a
hoodie type stuff oh yeah you were
full-bone you were full-blown uh Surfer
who just got done he's going to find a
bag real quick you were trying to jump
the gate in a rental Community we were
staying in yes just to be a dirt boy I
know I literally had like Toby do not
jump to dude it's all it shouldn't have
been locked there's no street lights
that's all you wanted to do was hop the
gate no I had no yeah you did no then
explain the m80s I found in your pocket
those were cherry bombs first of all
yeah I got it straight narc those were
[__] flab crackers you were their
films selling fake Disney passes hey man
that gate should have been unlocked and
I would have been right over that fence
I would have it would have been nowhere
but that's how I realized that is like
the Dirtbag skateboarder in you because
I was just like he's gonna jump it I can
I can I ride up a fence in my day I knew
that's what you were doing you were
looked up look left look right and then
like the the hoisting up of the pants I
was like I told me don't [__] do that
you're like why I'll be out don't do it
don't do cake the hoisting up with the
pants and then throwing your plastic bag
from 7-Eleven oh yeah throwing the goods
over first I'll see you on the other
side
please come back we had a good time down
there in Florida I'll tell you that it
was a good time man shout out to Disney
a lot of drinks a lot of Bernies That's
my kind of vacate that is a couple of
coasters and a big man on a couple of
coasters any uh yeah fit everyone too
huh barely but yeah I mean it was close
you got in I'm happy you got in Space
Mountain my my concern was my knees were
sticking out so much oh man you were
catching you were catching looks as we
were as we were driving by the line
before we departed into space there's a
couple Engineers there with the
clipboard being like
I don't know maybe let's see
increase the propulsion 25 you come back
headless
yeah it was a great [__] time shout
out to Florida I love Florida Florida
catchers have been around Florida's a
good time a lot I mean we tried but we
couldn't get reservations to drive a
tank and blow up a car that's kind of
well that's the kind of Vibes Florida
comes with all day that's open all day
that's a business that operates seven
days a week we couldn't get in because
they had corporate events corporate
events I assume I assume it was uh
instead we had to wait in a 25 minute
line in Miller's to get a table what was
it called Miller's Ale House yeah shout
out to the smoking bones down there that
place is all right it's just like shitty
casual bones that I'm all right with
sign me up give me some dude you could
order to your table a bucket of beers
which is good time by me the kid at
Smokey Bones asked is like you want that
in a pint or you want the big one I was
like let's do the big one yeah always go
big who knows what that was it was 48
ounces
came with duct tape the table under my
hands you want to sleep you want the
three liter of IPA
yeah
bring him over straighten me out no I
like that I like a place where you can
order you ask you ask for a beer and
they ask you what size do you want
that's all right that don't happen
everywhere that's a that's a that's a
real nice thing you want the big boy
yeah I want the big boy you ever get the
mug
there's a mug not a pint but a mug sure
mugs they're smaller they can kind of
kick rocks because you only get a cold
one the first round then they're
backtracking they're coming out of the
dishwasher yeah it's got a hot one uh I
I concur with that they do the mugs at
McSorley's Ale House down there on the
lower or on the East Village it's like
the oldest Irish Pub or whatever sure
sure they only have two kinds of beers
light in the dark and you order one and
they give you two it's my kind of math
it's my kind of beer man you all take
well I'll take one dark and they hand
you two little mugs because like they're
mostly foam and they're little so it's
like oh hey hey
you know I think it gives you like a
real sailor Vibe I like it yeah I'm
punching up pints it up yeah give me 16
or nothing yeah except for those little
beers we got in Japan at uh in Epcot
we're pretty banging yeah that was uh I
think that was a language barrier with
me I didn't I tried to order and I tried
to order in the native tongue and I got
a little tip I don't know I was [__]
up by that point if I'm being honest
with you speak in Spanish
I don't know what he's doing yeah it was
uh it was great man I love Florida's a
Great Escape in the winter time from the
Northeast you go down there you get some
fun in the sun it's Trailer Park
California man oh it's great dude
smoking cigs in the pool we didn't get
kicked out of the Airbnb we didn't get
kicked out but have you heard anything
any Rumblings I did we ladies and
gentlemen we smoked about four million
heaters oh let me pull up I did get a
message that I didn't I have I didn't
have the courage to open it from the I
don't it could be good or bad we're
gonna find out right now actually I
don't have because they're missing a
fitted sheet I don't have it
because I have such PTSD from the
previous Airbnb yeah I don't like
opening the messages the day after sure
of like hey we found your condoms and
you're you know you're whatever yeah
um I was peeing in that shower boy how
many times you pee in a pool
how many what how many because we didn't
really talk about it but obviously how
many times did I pee in the hot tub that
the four of us were in at one point two
I totally didn't pee while having a
conversation with Toby what the [__]
dude
drop the Bud Lights are kicking in yeah
dude I had 19 beers I didn't get up to
go to the bathroom what were you
thinking that I wasn't sitting a tub
full of piss do you work uh hey it's all
welcome to Florida it's all good yeah I
mean they told you that the airport dude
yeah any pool has pee in it I was peeing
most of the time that I was down there
yeah I did pee a lot a lot it says hey
we are happy to have hosted you during
this time I hope you have enjoyed your
the home we prepared for you and then
it'll be Orlando everything the Orlando
area has to offer we would love to have
you and your family and friends back
with us real soon really we gave you a
five star review on Airbnb and hope you
can place the review for us as well look
at that come on babies you can't hold a
good crew down there you go shout out to
airbnbs that don't have cameras yeah no
kidding my kind of spot yeah
to look the other way they're also like
hey no smoking and this is my derp I go
it says no it just says no smoking and I
go my my legal my very little legal
understanding is I go well that's in the
house right sure it doesn't say no
smoking on the property it wasn't there
was no no smoking sign in the backyard
yeah yep and that's what I'm going by
yeah mostly swamp but I I had ripped it
off when we were right now Gators got to
it yeah that was an all right trip shout
out to the [__] homies everybody
signed up that was our uh patreon goal
fulfillment the next one we got cooking
which is creeping up very very soon yeah
is that there Indie 500 oh yeah hippie's
gonna be in a car
now I heard about that you said Shaq was
brought up he's DJing something I think
Shaq's DJ and he's got something going
on down here at the Super Bowl too yeah
a guy gets a big party
what do you think he plays I think he
plays the violin what do you mean what
do you think you should get a pair of
Shaq shoes and try to get him to
autograph them yeah that's all right
I'm just gonna if I see him I'm just
gonna post up and go give me the rock
just [__] just try to back them down
wherever you shake them open hit me hit
me
you know what I wanted to ask you oh God
what's that
um I had a slight not let's say the
communication issue with uh with a
um Uber driver
earlier today
um
it was all jammed up on my place okay
and I was like listen we're we're gonna
walk over uh to to another Street come
around and bust a UE
and he's like what bust a yui yeah is
that yui is that not a universal thing I
don't know for you and you know that
Busta yui yeah flip a [__] flip a [__]
Jesus Christ
I'll never speak to someone like that
this is a goddamn family program I
apologize
um
[Laughter]
I was being polite right buddy
I wasn't I wasn't full blast I didn't
have my phasers in the underwater War my
my my my uh DNA reigned Supreme yeah no
I was I was letting it out slug oh yeah
a little bit and then clenched and go
yeah a little bit more clinch I wanted
to be a gentleman about it okay you
can't look a man in the eye and Go full
board but I'll say this if you ever saw
me while you guys were in in and I'm
pretty sure you peed sitting down at the
table one day too just let it go my
bathing suit was still wet that counts
if you ever saw me down at the deep end
just chilling there man yeah I was
letting it on you weren't doing laps you
were in the porta potty
all right you missed out Peter the
pool's all right everybody knows that
that's all hot water anyway yeah boils
right off yeah I mean I don't think it
was that hot
it wasn't 212 all right
it was boiling
anyway bus to yui yeah I don't think
that's uh maybe not I mean was he a
Philly thing was he from uh it could be
an American thing yeah you know what I
mean he would he could have uh he could
have been from a different country and
maybe not known the lingo I don't think
it was Connecticut let's put it down
sure he might have not he might have
just not known Buster you a U-turn but
you you turn sure yeah yeah cause I got
in the cars what are you talking about
he was like yui where's yui street I'm
like nah where the hell's yui street I
was like bust a U-turn dude yeah no
that's uh that's probably just a
language of error I have to assume uh
but all that being said we got a goddamn
uh Family episode on our hands yeah guys
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
it's just the best way to do it a lot of
submissions but the uh the homies get
the first crack at it we got a little
bit of a backlog that we're working
through but we're getting everybody
shout out shout out to him all right
this one's from a little step thank
shout out to Toby's cat I believe right
there you go damn I know little homie
had internet access yeah and apparently
credit card information
[Laughter]
uh this is a home run ever used bungee
cords for something indoors
[Laughter]
refrigerator door
hops Bungie that didn't I never thought
about that until this question they are
an outdoor slash Automotive sure you
utility tool or whatever that ain't
indoors when the bungee cord rolled on
the scene sometime in the when it came
on our the Foley family radar was
sometime in the mid 80s yeah and my dad
thought he
was a mechanical engineer oh yeah
wrapping it around double looping
putting them together oh yeah dude those
things
I saw him get whiplashed with those
things so many times God damn it I had
one snap off and hit me in the head so
[__] hard when I was working
construction oh my god dude cause we
never had enough to strap down the stuff
on the truck that was our way it was our
famous last words ah that ain't going
nowhere just shaking I ain't going
nowhere I think you're doing 60 on the
turnpike one of them [__] snapped we
had the shittiest for a construction
company we had the worst bungees dude on
record we had we had the same four most
of my life I remember thinking money we
had the we had the black ones the black
rubber ones now ours had the little
Speckles that was rich guy stuff red
that were covered with the thread yeah
yeah that was rich guy [__] to me really
yeah we had the we had like the black
utility ones that had no give in them
that was pretty much like a rope with
two hooks oh I know what you're talking
about though that's what we banged with
dude if you pulled those things really
hard they'd rip a leg off oh man those
things did the black rubber ones yeah oh
you got your foot up on the one side of
the pickup truck
trying to get it over the bar those
things wrap down some PVC pipe deadly oh
you used to use those Landscaping to
hold the gate up yeah yeah yeah oh
that'll scratch the [__] out yeah they
didn't have a lot of play in them uh and
then when they did they would hit a nice
sweet spot when they would get stretched
out enough but then they just turned
into like rope again like they get loose
all the stretch was going out he really
had to bring it over a couple of links
we yeah yeah everybody has in their set
of bungee cords has one that's only
stretchy on one side yeah yeah you gotta
get like a real [__] real good pull
on her yikes we uh also too we had one
for a while when my mom was whipping
that Sebring convertible I would have to
put my bike in the back like I was going
to like my buddy's house or whatever
going on the shore or something if if we
had to move the bike when I was too
young for to like really ride somewhere
they would do that I'm surprised they
would take I don't know what it would
have took for my dad to take our bikes
down the shore
maybe rent one down there one day but we
weren't allowed to bring our wow we were
going down for a while like we were
going down for like you know it wasn't
we weren't going down for the weekend or
the week like I'd go stay with my aunt
who was you know bartending down there
my mom would go to work so I'd be down
for like maybe two weeks or whatever
those kids bringing their own bike down
the shore yeah you felt real cool see
some dork on a beach cruiser that said
like Gary's bikes on it meanwhile I'm
[__] I'm bunny hopping on my on my
Schwinn dude [__] out of here can't tell
me nothing on the Wildwood Boardwalk
dude those beach cruisers to a fat
little kid that might as well suck might
as well try to drive the space shuttle
and now I have appreciation for them I
have a grand appreciation Cruiser we got
we I got I got one now down at the you
know like family just it's a girl's bike
yeah they all have the dip the dip they
don't have a bar that goes across they
all have the low dip no they have the
dip they have the bar that goes across
nah not the ones that I see I'm telling
you are you sure I own one with it let
me see a picture of it
they for sure do yeah what have one a
bar that goes straight across yeah yeah
here's one right here this is something
similar to what I have I mean visually
yeah right there that thing's mean I
gotta
free gift sign there I'll sign up real
quick
there
all right I'll give it to you all right
I'll give it to you that's the thing you
just said but that's not the traditional
traditional beach cruiser sure girls
bikes like even growing up we had the
the microwaves have had them like this
yeah yeah that's a proper beach cruiser
I do know what you mean the ladies bike
the ladies yeah with the pom-poms
you got to get in mind you know what I
didn't mind a man's Beach you know what
I didn't mind the little streamers that
came out of the girls handlebars and
you're worried about the frame and you
got streamers those guys are pretty
sweet let you know you're a cruiser make
them match your underwear a little freak
oh [__] little uh but I remember one
time dude my mom was rocking a pair of
white kids and I knew we were just built
different at this point as a as a as a
family unit we had nothing to tie we
didn't have the bungee to close the
trunk so we needed something to tie so
she took out the shoelace from her kid
and tied it around and I was like damn
you that is what I got better Barefoot
anyway I was like You Belong with a
space shuttle that was that was like
that scene from [__] Apollo 13 where
we're like we got to make this fit into
that and this is what we got she [__]
yeah rigged it up real good shoelace
took his shoelace out of her white Ken
and hide it around I remember my mom I
broke my shoelace and she tied it
together
trying to get that one through the hole
oh that's a bad luck that's a real bad
luck dude you're bad if your shoes have
two knots in them that's a [__] bad
one you got one down by the toe and one
up and the regular nut skipping a couple
holes Kip how about that bespoke post
baby you mean box of awesome you like
that box awesome you like looking cool
in front of your friends when they show
up at your house for a little
get-together Flex on some dorks all of a
sudden you pull out a tomahawk put that
right next to his head on the drywall
when he walks in the front door now I'll
make you a nice cocktail with more of my
products from box awesome sure gang we
love box awesome here we love bespoke
post you get cool guy stuff for cool guy
times it's a good good time you get
cocktail stuff you get stuff for the
home bar you get stuff for the outdoors
stuff for the winter it's fun fun do
yourself a favor and pick one up yeah
their Terra box looks well let me tell
you it looks awesome uh it's got a huge
Crocodile Dundee type knife made by bear
phones and if you know anything about me
what are we doing I roll with a
Crocodile Dundee type knife at all time
let's go uh is you're going with big
knife it's got to be a Crocodile Dundee
there's no other there's no other knife
you know a rainbow maybe but I'm a
crocoder if you're showing up to a St
Patrick's Day party and you want to make
it interesting and you don't got a
crossbow on you what are you doing yeah
uh you get 90 90 90 of everything in
your box is from a small up and coming
brand you only pay a fraction of what
these boxes are worth uh you go to the
box of awesome.com take the little fill
out a little form there and picks the
right box of awesome I know what kind of
fella you are or lady you get 20 off
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com and other code
garbage and check out that's box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com code
garbage do it yeah Kip this one's for
manscape oh baby best in a Biz that
manscaped Best In The Biz keeps the nuts
clean keeps them not smelling good a lot
of good stuff they just upped it one now
they're taking on your face yeah so I
don't think you is the same one I use on
my gonads on my mustache which I've been
doing
walking around smelling nuts all day
which I don't mind nothing wrong with it
I feel that smell like a gym locker room
gang do yourself a favor get over there
to manscape they got the beard trimmer
Pro kit out uh-huh tighten you up real
real nice Valentine's Day coming up take
care of the backyard and take care of
the front yard yeah the beard hedger
gives you 20 hair cutting Lanes Hachi
Machi that's a lot the thing I'm banging
with on my face sometimes is Ford that
ain't no good get a tight fade I've seen
in the commercial uh I think it's
connected there you know what it's real
easy yeah yeah for sure yeah no yeah
yeah no totally uh it's waterproof you
can shave anywhere and since manscape
wants you to have all the tools for the
job they're throwing in a beard brush
comb and scissors to make make you look
like a million bucks there you go and
start looking like a million bucks by
saving a little bit of cash so you get
20 off and free shipping with our code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code garbage
at manscape.com and say one more gosh
darn time uh the manscape beer hedger
Pro kit the premium so solution for face
grow main do it there you go I'm back to
the show back to the show uh we've
talked about this one this isn't funny
though this is from doroli Foley's
director scarf uh that's pretty good uh
never have one red is it garbage you
have to Google what time exactly does
direct positive hit
buddy I've been there I respect that you
gotta play the game and it's tough to
Peg it down sometimes you don't know it
depends on their Bank it depends on your
bank it depends on if it's an a whatever
payment man yeah but I've been there
Daddio but I don't care I don't
understand why that catches a bad
[__] rap High Finance people do that
[__] that's all time trading getting in
getting out at the right time that's
High Finance for dirt bags you know what
it's going to bounce at 505. hey what
time does the funding land I need money
doesn't matter if it's all the money I
have sure it's the I need my money I
never did direct deposit until now yeah
never once that I sign up for that at a
job I didn't trust that [__] as far as I
could throw it I'll be here Friday at
noon to pick up my check well they were
always the thing that always sucked was
for a while it would be the direct
deposit would be a little delayed and
typically when I was ever starting a new
job I was jammed up I was I didn't do
that paycheck when I was before I
started you know what I mean so the the
the three weeks of training or whatever
it is you know you start a job you
missed the cycle sure you don't get
yourself you're not getting paid till
the 88th of the month you're like what
the [__] dude let's go get the goddamn
chatter they don't mind me sleeping here
[__] hemmed up I know man that [__]
was [__] there is a difference
between like a guy at at Chase Bank
looking at millions of dollars moving
around and a guy outside of a 7-Eleven
at 2 A.M like and he's refreshing his
Bank of America app dude I've done that
outside of a set like as a proper adult
all like
this podcast might have been happening
like when we first started I was posted
up outside that 7-Eleven out front of
[__] fat black waiting for something
wait for something to click
get a hot meal in you uh-huh get some
taquitos maybe a slice of that good
pizza they throw out bag of Yik Yak nah
call the guy and tell him you got green
lights I got a five minute window from
when they stop selling booze and when I
get my [__] money yeah exactly go in
there and try to get a couple rounds in
you
couple of shots for me and my friends
hey we're closing up God damn it
yeah never trusted that never trusted
direct deposit always got my check took
it immediately to a check cashing place
or the check or the bank the bank I
remember when somebody told me that
it it it it it I went from
a bachelor's degree in dirt bag to a
doctorate in scumbag yeah when I found
that out I can't remember where I was
hemmed up somewhere they're like you can
just take it to the bank that the
check's written on they have to cash it
but sometimes you get hit up with like
Sun Valley Crest banked out in Idaho and
you're [__] jammed up I used to try
to do that at that when I worked at the
supermarket they were because it was a
National Corporation they were out of
some tiny Rinky Dink Bank in Seattle or
something I'm over here trying to get my
180 out on a Friday I'll go get some
booze and some Bernies with the boys and
I got a [__] I gotta catch a red eye
to Seattle what's up back in Seattle got
to do with me being jammed up in Bucks
County I know let's go make good with
the [__] scratch I take it over to
Commerce they whacked me for eight bucks
I'm [__] here you're taking four
percent of my goddamn check it's half a
pack of heaters
at eight bucks back then that was
probably close to two packs of heaters
pack of heaters that's where five bucks
back when I was banging a couple of tall
boys
let's go get a 30 rack call it a goddamn
weekend man what a great question can't
tell me [__] uh this one's from Dr
fantana
ten dollar homie which is the most
popular Homie by the way ten dollar
homie have you ever hitched a trailer or
U-Haul to a minivan
that's a bad look we never had to do
that because my family worked in
construction so we always had access to
a shop truck or a pickup truck or a like
a box truck or something we did me and
my brother rented a U-Haul one time to
help him move and it sucked that's the
only time we ever did a proper U-Haul
but like a U-Haul truck not a trailer
not a trail like a big box truck sure
you crashed it when he was pulling into
the the driveway of his new apartment
building whenever I saw anybody
throughout my life
no matter what was pulling it it could
be a [__] Naval battleship
if somebody was pulling one of those
little U-Haul trailers I assumed that
they were in the worst possible position
that anybody sure ever yeah I used to
when we drive by something like that on
the highway I'd be like God damn
throwing change at them
yeah I get but they just look brutal
they don't look great and it's always
connected to a car
yeah always I don't think I have the
torque to pull off
pull it up to U-Haul like I need to skip
skip and town packets yeah I'm gonna
return this at another location
I'm not bringing this back here you got
something you can get you're trying to
get your get your hands off what do you
got in the way of a handshake deal
yeah that's uh
that's tough but I get it if you have a
car we're currently doing a hot on your
Trail package right now
need to get away
there's need to get away and gotta get
out yeah oh
yikes yeah they're tough tough look man
we did I think I had mentioned at one
point hold on that's the same thing even
though it's different with the there's
little winnebagos like little camping
little winnebags and those camping uh
the pop-up Johns yes the the the the
ones you pull on man I used to see those
and be like [__] let's get a hotel lady
it was cool to me because my neighbor
had one the pop-up and that was my first
introduction a lot of bees in there oh
man a crime for a wasp nest
catch you can't catch me running out of
there dude's taking my shirt off jumping
in the pool trying to find water
yeah oh those get real hot might as well
beat the Devil's Den
remember how it smelled too very nothing
like a wasp nest I'll tell you that this
summer time going to battle in a couple
of those two tree cans of raid ah I
think I told you before I brought the
Montego back up here I left it was the
Monty they shout out rest in peace of
the Mercury Montego it was parked in my
mom's driveway for about a dude three
years uh not moved not registered not
nothing
and I came home to get it one time to
bring it up here I was gonna take a new
shot at life I was gonna be a guy with
the car you know really [__] really
try to do it man
and my mom goes there's a wasp nest in
that tail light you better watch
how did they get in there there's a
little crack obviously I had a couple
like I bet a couple fender benders it
created a little a little access road
for him a wasp nest in your tail lights
and I go I'll be fine man these things
new must have they must have heard I was
in the neighborhood looking for beef
dude these things came out they they
didn't even wait for me to approach
after sitting there for a year they
probably had developed in like having
Universal Health Care oh yeah they were
all they're launching missions to space
they were unified they they played as a
team I'll tell you that
I brought a knife to a wasp fight and
that wasn't work dude I [__] hiked I
hightailed it down to the [__] Street
away from my mom I told you I told you I
go in I get two cans of raid I come out
who won't want everyone's getting it
yeah oh man so what happened if I
remember correctly I really doused him
right I really got him going you got
listen it sucks you got to but at the
same time I didn't
always two cans yeah but I didn't trust
they get in the car because if they're
in the car and I I go for a stroll and
they're they're lying you know what I
mean they're hiding in a back seat
waiting to get me hey wait till you get
on the highway looks like Good Fellas
look at the piano wire and [__] knife
me in the neck
so I waited I think I came back the
following week to make sure they were
dead and I remember popping the trunk
man this was like this big posted up
right there oh dude that's funny yeah
it's tough when your car gets bees that
is a bad one yeah we also had in the
same thing as the U-Haul we had uh we
did have the bubble on top of the wood
we had the Woody the Wood panel red I
thought that was rich guy [__] anybody
putting anything up on the roof a roof
rack or something skis make sense
yeah no I'm saying if you have a ski
rack I could see how that would be a
fancy thing sure this thing I mean we
use I remember I don't think I ever saw
it on the car it was behind the garage
and got filled with water and then grew
frogs in it that's the extent of our
doesn't it have like a kangaroo on it
wasn't that the brand yeah something
like something like that I always
thought that was weirdo [__] yeah it had
yeah we never use I never remember using
it I just remember getting frogs and
then we had to get rid of it it was
never on like a normal dad's car it was
always the dad that was a little
hey
I guess we had it on the minivan we had
it on the Woody we had like that red
wood not all the time no I mean I've
never I don't think I ever saw it on the
car hmm
probably ran out about there's no way my
dad was rocking with that on the Jeep no
way pulling up to a job site with one of
those things you [__] need to lose
the deal
need to get the boot no guy with a
bubbles building my house take that
draft dodging [__]
you take that commy [__] elsewhere this
is America God damn it [__] hippie
yeah you got the [__] out I don't care
where you're camping I always say every
time I saw one of those I was definitely
an acoustic guitar somewhere in that car
yeah
uh all right this one's from JP Henry
know anybody that has their keys hooked
to their belt loop
Toby is that that's a T-bone he's a
carabiner guy occasional yes yeah it's a
bad look usually you've moved out of it
a little bit
can I say this
There's real Roadie Vibes which he's you
were way more that
than you are now
sure you're definitely a little more new
yorkified in your own way you still keep
your own style all that kind of stuff
still a big dork yeah but you but you've
lost some of that uh some of that [__]
the city has taken some of that away
from you yeah let's in a good way and
and now I got a little cash to upgrade
my situation
to what where I mean where do you put
your keys here in my backpack oh this
guy's got backpack this guy's got
transport money yikes
about to throw in anybody's face but I
do have a 49.99 school bag I do feel
like the key situation is a good
indication of garbage or not or I feel
like the worse you're doing the more
keys you have yeah it's probably true
it's probably true yeah I mean key wise
now there was a point we got one to hear
we got one at hoodies or two Tooties
actually five we got a lot of locks on
this board and guns and wasps
keep a big one
down by the basement I know how to
communicate with them okay
um
I got two for my apartment two for here
I got four Keys mailbox key five five
six what do I got yeah it goes you gotta
go little Keys now right do you have any
keys on your ring that you don't know
what it is no but for most of my life my
mother had keys that I think that's a
lie I don't know what this is let me say
it I don't know what that is hahaha
that I genuinely have no idea I can tell
you what it is it's a Medco I used to
make them I used to work at all I used
to work at a locks it's a deadbolt key
let's do a deadbolt this isn't to a
regular door that's a deadbolt right
there yeah maybe it's a deadbolt on my
door but I think the other one does that
maybe I have two deadbolts oh that might
be like the big Locker deadbolt Locker
like that
yeah yeah but I have another why not a
dead ball I have another like big bolt
action lock on there you do you have
three locks on your door I guess I only
use actually I use all three of them
nice neighborhood huh Jesus Christ
and lost I also have bees once you get
to the blast store you'll be all right
um yeah for a while my mom I felt like
she kept
all the keys from everywhere we've ever
lived sure probably went back and rooted
around took some stuff after she left go
back and get the cable box right right
before Christmas okay look
I got a half a bag of chips
um I have
three keys
I had some pot you have two to hear you
just don't carry them no I have one to
my door
and I have a fob for the front door yeah
a lot of that first time ever yeah I'm
not a fob man I'm a high school steel
you need it catch me in the streets
regulate any keys off this property
we're damn good too all right let's see
uh this is from grab a long time maybe
never had one red are you garbage if
growing up your mom went to the local
Chinese takeout place to pick up white
rice for Taco Tuesday at the house
that's [__] crazy
I don't hate it what what was the taco
so what are you doing rice taco Tuesdays
guess rice maybe rice for the taco you
know yeah yeah that's not good I mean
also it's also white rice it's not like
a specialty item you're going to pick up
uh we have this like it's [__] white
rice get some Uncle Ben's if you're
doing that even Rice-A-Roni uh I'll say
this that's crazy I'll say this is a
Chinese restaurant for taco Tuesday
that's just come on this ain't Epcot but
the white rice is the the best you're
gonna get top shelf
and Tacos doesn't even go together so
you're going to get a thing that doesn't
make sense that you could also make at
your house to not make sense do tacos
have rice in them burritos burritos I
guess I'm sure you could dabble maybe oh
yeah or maybe on a side that's a tough
look but not even white rice you go to a
Mexican restaurant you'll get white rice
no rice and beans
maybe that's that's white rice but it's
mixed right or it don't even depends I
think it's got a little little color a
little juice but that might come from
the the beans Chipotle does a white rice
with a lime Chipotle does do a white
rice
that goes in the burrito and we said
burrito sure white rice in a burrito all
day oh hit me up what if you're doing
burritos at your house that's crazy
Taco Tuesday
that's all right burrito burrito at the
house I wouldn't shake a stick at they
never had a burrito until I was an adult
yeah no me either like like I was dating
my wife I think the first time I had a
burrito yeah it was a real pick eater
Patty didn't go for it
no we would do tacos at the crib I
wouldn't I do nuggies or something I
have her make me some nuggies and
applesauce
couple of screaming cans of [__] Coke
let's go
to the Border baby this is PA let's go
do like a nice Taco yeah that's anything
being
prepared like that from outside sources
is gonna fall under the trash category
that's like semi-homemade [__] you know
yeah yeah I don't know but it's like and
if I was the Chinese spot I would be
suspect about that wait you just want
four white races five be like what the
[__] are you up to who cares you're not
getting a fortune cookie with that I'm
losing your money you come to my place
you're not getting a fortune cookie in
the Duck Sauce in the house custard yeah
just buying [__] that's like going to
an Irish bar and just asking for a thing
of mashed potatoes get the [__] out
crazy
um all right this one's from Tony two
hands uh is it garbage if you bring your
own Furniture to a hotel lamp pillows
Etc why I mean dude if you're fully if
you're bringing a recliner to a that's a
tough look
a lamp if it's especially one of those
like uh Sun lamps or whatever if you
have like some sort of deficiency I'll
let it slide you know what I mean it's a
vitamin D dude yeah if that's the case
sure this guy's shooting if you're from
adult videos yeah if you're bringing
your own lighting rig or something
or even a pillow ring light in the
rubber sheets
a specialty I'll give you if it's
something like how long are you staying
a lamp I don't know man that's tough
yeah that's wild I don't even like
taking my pillow anywhere because it
gets the travel on it then it's like
when you were a kid it was the greatest
thing of all time in the car maybe if we
were going to like
the Poconos or something I'll bring a
pillow for the ride as a kid a long ride
with your pillow that's what I'm saying
but that wasn't all the time now that
was like a a ride and we're staying
somewhere for a while but the way that
fit up against the door
otherwise your [__] neck comes out
crinked like a goddamn french fry dog
snap ya oh man that sucks all right this
one's for Mary
first time long time when I was a kid we
went to the local dock with my dad and
he asked somebody if he could have some
of their lobster Nets he made a soccer
goal out of them for us with some PVC
pipes is this garbage
what the [__] tough Lobster a lobster
net soccer net
so he went he went down a couple buoys
hanging in there
that's nuts dude there's seaweed on your
on your goal looks like the wall at a
seafood joint that's what I picture a
couple of Bobbers you know what I mean a
bunch of algae stuck in the one side 40
bucks you hit that starfish
um so so X was very resourceful if he
didn't have the cash and he's a Do-it
himself guy and he he gave you something
that's dope so I'll give you that that's
cool as a dad so he wasn't using it for
lobster purposes he went down to where
the pizza lobsters play soccer he went
down to the place where people do
lobstering
sure and he said do you guys have any
Nets that you're throwing away I guess
it's trash but yeah man you made a deal
now if he had a bunch of money and still
did that that's real trash sure if he
could afford the but still also
resourceful but you could go by if you
don't want to spend the money on a
soccer net you can buy it still buy the
PVC and then go buy your own netting
spend nine bucks on a net or whatever
yeah I mean it ain't that crazy
expensive you got a crab pot basketball
hoop
so feel your season yeah they're playing
well this year
get that Cajun season in your eyes
if I can give you something to cry about
[__]
yeah that's nuts hit you with the corn
on the cob look out coming in Hachi
um we made a lacrosse net when we were
in high school okay yeah with what
um
uh not spare parts I think we got PVC
and then bought the net yeah
or like Sportsnet or something yeah a
replacement net and do it yourself yeah
my pop wasn't involved in that though
yeah we were big on just building our
[__]
because construction workers don't like
buying [__] that they think they can do
you know what I mean it's very like
I can do half of this and then I'll
figure that's why everything sucked in
our house you know what I mean the
doghouse was never finished the [__]
basement was never finished Uncle Den
came over did the basement he probably
picked up all their side work hit the
[__] road
there's no outlet covers on it still to
this day that's a thing of spackle down
there open buckets of spackle at the
crib from when the basement was
attempted to be redone I mean they're
still trim missing sure yeah it's a lot
the drop lighting the lighting isn't in
the drop ceiling could do a lot with
those speckle buckets once they're empty
plated drums on them oh sit on them yeah
those buckets those five gallon buckets
were just a steady at our house good
time yeah yeah yeah they're a good time
um a bunch of Legos in there
guy still a little still a little bit of
a smackle in there there's people that
use them for tools in the trade sure and
my a guy they make those things that go
which I love the Home Depot John the
little covers oh yeah it's a little
organizer you put in there you can put
the big stuff in The Bigs and then
that's great I worked for a real so he
was a good guy but he was a real
psychopath
um cleanliness he was like a master
everything he built his own home through
the wiring do the plumbing he redid
kitchens and I used to have to clean out
the van and clean that bucket out I tell
you what though I mean you get that
thing nice and clean
that was that was always the problem
this guy worked with he used the bucket
and he never it was just dumped in there
she'd be like hey hand me the you know
the 3 8 ratchet head and you just have
to it's you would try to get through it
but you would just end up having to dump
it and then putting everything I'm like
dude there's got to be a better way than
this every single time looking for a
screwdriver just dumping out 50 pounds
of tools yeah you don't need all that
crap either it's a pair of wire snippers
wire cutters feeling that's all that's
all the guys used was that in the drill
let's go yeah uh
um all right let's see he what do we got
what do you say this one's this is from
Cody has your mother-in-law ever stomped
a mouse with her foot like a bug that's
that's a different cut abroad right
there she's stomping on mice Barefoot
yikes I feel it smush Ah that's never
look but I guess if you see him your
reaction I I have seen people like chick
get em type thing like that's just the
react that's the fighter flight at him
how quick is she what is she an X-Men I
don't know that ice aren't also that
quick they don't have a lot of muscle
you know what I mean they're not that
quick as I as you get older and you
realize that they're a little dumb
I said how are you
um they get a little bit of that poison
in them too they get real I I said yeah
I'm not looking for water he can't do he
was sitting right next to me on the
armchair sitting there typing a paper
smoking a heater in the apartment like
you do
and this thing for I look over he was
sitting on the [__] arm rest of the
couch just [__] all goofy am I you're
God then he doesn't move and he can't
freaks you out even more that he ain't
scared and he runs he's [__] this
guy's on fentanyl right now
hey I don't know what I did could you
get that Eighth Street
forget what I did I didn't step on them
I know that much maybe put him in a bag
or put a smoke in his mouth and lit it
up for him hey buddy any left right
what do you want what do you want your
last meal to be I could whip you
something
I got white rice and barbecue sauce your
choice
I've had that before yeah me too man it
ain't that bad it wasn't too shabby
white rice and ketchup
uh this one's running Mr Uranus 2005
ever fought off a raccoon no no but I
just saw a video one and I've got a
little girl they're rabid so if they
attacked a rabbit that's what that 100
I'm like 90 positive they're little
homies otherwise yeah otherwise they'll
come up shake your hands I don't think
sandwiches I think they're if let me get
up let me get some eyes on that I don't
think they're always rabbit if they
attack I think if you catch them off
guard if because what are you saying or
weren't we talking about somebody yeah a
friend a friend of my families that
walked by the trash can yeah it jumped
out yeah I don't think that was rabbit I
think it was for sure rabbit oh really
yeah yeah it's they're I I at least I
think it's there's probably a number of
most attacks are rabid uh they're more
likely to attack if they are rabid but
healthy raccoons can also attack you
yeah sure of course if you catch them
off guard they're in the middle of
eating eating dinner yeah no uh rabies
scared rabies I think was my number
that's his fears or something which is
like foaming out there the late 90s or
early 90s because I saw a movie called
Cujo adding too young of an age that's
what I had to clip that doll it was no
that was Old Yeller this was a rabbit
because you got it too though he
survived damn somebody [__] put an
APB on a good joke Cujo too yeah he's
teaching at inner city school turning
his life around uh no I don't yeah yeah
of course yeah I think he I think you're
not gonna spoil it all right yeah Hugo
dies I'm assuming yeah he dies there's
no way the Rabid the evil dog last at
the survives at the end of the movie I
haven't seen the film but I can
guarantee he's got a cigarette just
walks away oh yeah no but that's right
because that was a nice doggie it was
like a Saint Bernard or something like
that it wasn't like it was a German
Shepherd wasn't it no give that a [__]
what kind of dog was Cujo
it was like a it looked like a nice dog
it looked like Beethoven Bernard yeah
like Gary Bernard Saint Bernard Saint
Bernard so it was a nice puppy doggy
but man he got that liquor in him I got
all Sauced up turned into a different
guy I got a couple buddies like just
remember the one scene he had like the
bite on his nose of where he got bit by
the thing it looked like a little ant
hill and he was just ripping that town
apart
uh yes the rabies scared the [__] I mean
also the rabies treatment
scared me I don't know what it is
bathing tomato juice no yeah that's a
skunk idiot
I'll have a couple of bloodies and call
today okay you gotta get a buzz cut
you'll be back at school tomorrow no it
was needles in the stomach that were
apparently excruciatingly painful yeah
in the 80s rabies shots yes that and
tetanus I was I was always lingering
you'll get tetanus put shoes on you'll
get deadness Cujo gets ice with a
baseball bat all right there we go who
gets him the dad is this the same
writers as The Walking Dead Jesus Christ
ain't got a [__] 22 and laying around
they can click this [__] thing right
take them to the vet what the [__] he
[__] beat his fascist brains starting
to go through enough we're going at
rabies poor dog got bit now all of a
sudden he's catching a Louie today Jesus
Christ a true literary hero named Tad
does the deed really huh that's a tad
too much if you ask me
[Laughter]
I mean guys I'm not gonna make novel
dude I'm not gonna make literary jokes
poor coup is a fictional dog and
apparently who had a bit of an attitude
problem
that seems like a real thing no I don't
know anybody's ever been beat with a
baseball bat that didn't have a comment
all right that wasn't a big or not you
know what I mean there was that and then
there was also one that was a mob story
it was pushing
you rat [__]
[Laughter]
they even shot Cujo in the face so his
mom couldn't give him an open casket at
the funeral he cut his fingerprints off
it was real getting his balls off shoved
him in his [__] he was stealing
kibble apparently
because that came out and there was
another movie around the same time about
bees that scared me the bees it was like
Killer Bees or something like that I was
a comedian down in the South Killer Bees
really yeah yeah I think the story is
that's why zany has that balcony she
goes Killer Bees was such a big Act
that he was selling out so they added a
balcony just for him no kidding I think
they call it the house the bees built
shout out to him yeah shout out to
Killer Bees yeah there you go he's great
um the one that got me we watched as a
as a school they had like a movie night
in the cafe gym ethereum at night yeah
you had to come back to school yeah it
was like a Friday night it was like a
you know it wasn't like eight and a half
two no it was like Hey we're showing uh
we got a big projector we're gonna show
it we'll have popcorn like a little fun
how old are you
who young because this one shook me to
the core Mary Poppins arachnophobia
watching that in a dirty old gym at
night with the lights out man you can
feel the dust bunnies on your leg
thinking it's a goddamn spider get the
[__] out of here see I look at that as
like um like a Beetlejuice like a goof
Arachnophobia yeah wasn't that a comedy
no I think it was a straight movie no it
was a movie about Jeff Daniels and John
Goodman phoning it in
we call that a paycheck huh yeah I
thought there was like comedic elements
to that it was like a dark comedy
it's a dark comedy about things that can
kill you in the dark nonetheless
[__] that that's what scared you
Arachnophobia as an eight-year-old I saw
platoon when I was seven yeah that's
different I ain't in the [__] [__]
all right I'm I got spiders in the crib
they'll get you nah uh-uh you're nuts
maybe I was dead uh what year did
Arachnophobia come out 1990 really I was
four
you guys should have been watching that
that's what I'm saying I was five I was
in kindergarten
mom what were you doing niece sending me
to that God was it what was it rated it
wasn't rated pg4 I know that much PG-13
for sure 100 PG-13 yeah
back in the day too when those things
meant something
not now yeah no that was that one I mean
I didn't follow the plot I wasn't
picking up on the throwaway like back
when the movies for kids were real
spooky I was worried about the goddamn
spider it was about Killer Spiders sure
there was a big one at the end right I
don't think I made it to the end I think
I peed my pants and had to call my mom
I remember turning my back and [__]
you know I'm looking for some popcorn
security came over and yanked yet yeah
no I was done dude I didn't I I never
I'll never watch that movie ever again
hold you out of there never that one
that one like got me for some reason
okay because also I wasn't with my mom I
was with like my older brother who's
probably like you know getting into
hijinks or whatever with his boys yeah
he was just alone watching it by myself
no nobody to [__] nobody to sued the
fear you know uh that happened to me
with the original Halloween
um I was real young
had gone out trick-or-treating and came
back and it was by the time that had
already been like in syndication or
whatever it is you're watching that on
Halloween I won't even do that now dude
you're nuts I didn't do it on purpose so
you know that on Halloween they played
oh they play Halloween it was like TBS
or something like that and I come in I
think my brother was upstairs
putting his candy away or whatever he
was doing I was downstairs in the living
room my mom and dad were you know
whatever just Milling around and I was
down alone in the in the thing by myself
and that opening opening thing came on
with the song and I just got hypnotized
and just stared at it and saw the kid
murder the first couple people like
before the credits
dude the level of fear that ripped me
even like I don't think I slept for like
two nights I just laid there hearing
that song I couldn't go near a butter
knife for like two weeks I was petrified
oh yeah that's nuts to watch that I
wouldn't do that now I don't give me the
heebie-jeebies my cousin Michelle it was
Chucky for her
she was at the perfect age when Chucky
came out he didn't really I mean I was
young I remember being really young and
we tortured her with it because we were
all like five six years older yeah all
you had to do was say Chucky's coming
and she all you had to do was terrorize
her and she got scared oh yeah all you
had to tell her was the monsters are
real and she would get nervous
foreign
mask on and scaring the [__] out of my
little brother like I shouldn't have
been me and my dad would get our rocks
off oh dude there ain't nothing funnier
than scary kids I remember having a
Jason at the setup was about 35 minutes
I put the Jason mask on I still stood in
the closet and then my dad waited and it
was like hey Mike can you grab me
whatever out of the closet and there I
am
started crying he was like four dude
that's all we did when I was a kid my
dad would scare the [__] out of me and
my brother and we would all be dying as
long as you weren't the one getting got
yeah
not for sure for sure
uh let's do a couple more then we got a
ripper up here
uh speaking we touched on this a little
bit at the beginning uh this is from
Shire
fucker129er
shout out is it garbage to use a neck
pillow in the car does it make a
difference if you're driving a neck
pillow in the car is Bad News wild
that's no good yeah that's up there with
headphones in the car and I've seen it
oh I've done it really yeah why
um I would do it when I had the Montego
because it didn't have an MP like I
couldn't play
anything I was just at a CD player and
my CD collection ain't up to you know
ain't what it used to be paid off the
code and uh my girl would be like maybe
sleeping or doing whatever if we were
like driving to the shore from the shore
whatever and I would just put uh I had
no way of playing music I would just I
was like I could do was listen to the
radio I'd put a one airpod in and listen
to a podcast or whatever huh yeah one
okay
I think can you see the the wall on that
I think because it'll like it all like
what the law law is
say that one more time it's one of those
words I can't say LOL LOL what do you
say it's law law
yeah throw an L on there yeah yeah I do
that a lot I do that a lot small town
sheriff the lull's coming to get you uh
it's legal in Most states what
I am I gotta run for office this is wild
you gotta suspect it's because of people
being able to talk on their phones
hands-free
I'll give you that sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah for sure that makes sense uh
on that note one other thing you see in
Florida is to bring it back full circle
a lot of motorcycle riders no no helmet
yeah Sans helmet is something you don't
see that much we said it's a PA thing
you have the choice to wear a helmet or
not if you want to but most people do
most people do just [__] I mean you
know just pure Noggin out there that's a
lot dude that guy was ripping yeah he
was just cooking in and out real hot to
it the T-shirt was flapping up in the
T-shirt was flapping pair of jean shorts
uh-huh okay uh I will do this one then
we got a roll here this one's from
Thomas I'd love to know if Foley's
Christmas tree is still up now
I don't know I need to have boots on the
ground to confirm more than that yeah we
got it done pretty quick now pretty
quick we didn't go anywhere did we
you're asking me I'm just saying in
general no no we wouldn't uh yeah we put
it up late and wait wait wait did it get
taken and down when you moved
was that the Catalyst was the Catalyst
the move no we were in the news we were
in the new spot ah
um
no I think it was normal time okay I
think it was appropriate okay fair
enough afternoon the week after new year
did you put it in a bag or did you
litter your apartment hallway with
needles from the tree no the bird's big
on that
um if it was up to me
that's part of the job
uh I mean they haven't they started
putting they did it this year I there's
a notice in my building from me last
year
of if you need a bag please ask somebody
somebody did that too I did it it was it
looked like a goddamn murder yeah you
know somebody did it in our building and
it literally it's all first of all you
don't have to take it all the way out
they they you know they come and get it
or whatever so we ordered a bag wrapped
it up put it on the front door and and
they got rid of it but somebody just
[__] yeah it's a trail of [__]
death I did that yeah it ain't great it
ain't great yeah I didn't that didn't do
a tree this year we were on we were on a
move get into a tree yeah look at you
got it down we were down in uh I think I
knew that well I think we were I think
we were very busy the week leading up to
the holiday of course and then uh we
were going right down by the time we
were like going to buy one or gonna want
a small one it was like we're going down
to my the fam for the you know yeah I
couldn't treat it with that I couldn't
get away with that the last Christmas
tree I had in my in the apartment I
lived in Connecticut I smoked I I
vacuumed the whole way but only in front
of my door so it didn't look like it
started at my place you didn't put one
up at your place this year [__] no
really for me and the cat yeah no huh
that is pretty sad
I was chill dude at a Hanukkah Bush just
makes you feel more lonely around the
holidays uh we gotta wrap her up here
but we love you pal
sure
okay he come by my house anytime look at
the tree all right it's still up man
still got a couple weeks like that get
down gang we love you come get your
picture taken
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week